as the school year winds down for many
students experts point to a growing
problem that could be worse by the fall
since the pandemic began chronic
absences in the u.s schools have doubled
pre-pandemic about 8 million students
nationwide were chronically absent now
it's up to around 16 million meg oliver
visited a harper school district in
connecticut which is taking bold action
to reduce absent rates
it was a sweet surprise for these
excited 6th graders at mcdonough middle
school after a scavenger hunt
ice cream sandwiches
[Applause]
and a dj dance party with their teachers
and friends to participate the students
had to be in school for 90 percent of
april this is just one of many events by
the district to encourage attendance
principal marjorie rice we've had fear
factor events where staff has actually
eaten
insects teachers are eating insects
insects to entice students exactly is it
working it's working yes the kids do
love the events our efforts have shown
in our data that
we're improving our chronic absenteeism
reducing that rate improving our average
daily attendance but most importantly
students who maybe were disengaged in
the beginning we're starting to see them
coming to school
every day the u.s department of
education defines chronic absences as
students who miss at least 15 days of
school in a year according to the
organization attendance works trauma
family responsibilities or home
situations health or transportation
problems poverty housing and food
insecurity all contribute to chronic
absences
are absences higher than ever absolutely
we are having an attendance crisis as a
country hedy chang is the executive
director and president of attendance
works she says schools need to make kids
feel connected and engaged offer
tutoring and mentoring expand summer
learning and do at home visits when kids
aren't showing up is it too late to take
action right now before the end of this
school year absolutely not it starts
with that outreach
we need to make sure that we're reaching
out to students and families that's
exactly what hartford public schools are
also doing when did the home visits
really ramp up
last week we did 15
and the week before that we did 15 as
well wow ashley jackson is the middle
school student engagement specialist
you're going to follow the deck in that
order she helps put on events like the
scavenger hunt but also visits families
at home when students aren't showing up
to school how many students have you
been able to re-engage
a lot
i can't even put a number on it 8th
grader ashley quadra is one of the
students jackson has helped during the
pandemic her family moved and she no
longer qualified for school
transportation
jackson taught her how to take the
public bus riding the route with her if
you didn't have that do you think there
might have been a day where you thought
this is too much this is too hard i
don't need to go to school today yes
really
quadra now reaches out to students who
are often absent what do you tell them
why should they come back
because you need education to get
further in life because when you get
older you're probably going to want to
have your career and you can't make a
career out of no education because that
education is going to get you far in
life when you see your students smiling
when you see them engaged when you see
them doing these scavenger hunts how
does it make you feel it's impossible to
put it into words
it is the best feeling in the world
it just fills me with joy it fills me
with a ton of pride and a whole lot of
hope
shortly after we finished filming at the
middle school there was a deadly
drive-by shooting across the street our
cameraman heard the shots the school
went into lockdown and no students or
staff were hurt violence has also been
cited as a factor to contributing to
absenteeism a school spokesperson told
us everyone was rattled but they're
determined to persevere despite the
challenges they faced growing up
surrounded by violence there you go
right no one was hurt meaning no one was
struck by a bullet but hearing the shots
that rattles you and that changes your
conception of school isn't it safe can i
learn here where am i going with this
and that young girl put it so perfectly
i mean this education this is where it
starts if you want to change
circumstance it starts with the
education at a young age they have to be
able to get there for that i think the
big takeaway too is it's not too late to
take action you know even after i did
the interview with hedy chang i wanted
to volunteer at my daughter's school and
to like reach out tutor a mentor i think
this is a community effort right now
everybody has to step up it takes a
village right absolutely and as long as
you understand like tony is saying these
things that the children are dealing
with whether it's violence or bullying
or even just difficulty of doing your
assignments as parents as teachers we
all can join in and kind of get these
kids re-engaged in the classroom worried
about public schools we've got teachers
not signing up for the job or leaving
the job and then we've got kids doubling
the chronic absent rate that's a big
issue maybe it's a call to all parents
out there volunteer a little bit more of
your time thank you man we appreciate
you